support officiel ça oui en quoi le pass
and i ter sera bientôt exigée dès 12 ans
30 septembre ouais ouais 30 septembre
les enfants à partir de 12 ans
n'ayant pas le temps de faire le vaccin
sont toujours là bas des naissances pour
que les enfants je suis pas vieux
monsieur san ou nas pas non plus
devront eux aussi présenter un qr code
pour être autorisés à aller au
restaurant au cinéma ou pratiquer leurs
activités extrascolaires ce sont donc on
a peur aussi c'est qu'ils réduisent là
j'ai bien entendu parce que là c'est 12
ans et 2 mois c'est une situation qui
révolte certains parents alors que pour
d'autres c'était la solution alors on a
avec nous ce soir
sandrine mère de quatre enfants qui a
très peur du vaccin merci sandrine merci
d'être là cette contente date à côté
d'un stabilo boss
si vous demande de vo surligner vous dit
non
merci sandrine savoir dans sa peau on
agira d lépine qui est venu nous voir un
chirurgien orthopédique vous êtes contre
leva la vaccination pour les moineaux
je suis contre ce qui n'est pas une
vaccination car ce n'est pas un tel
vaccin un vaccin ça des antigènes dans
aucun des vaccins actuels en france me
adam qui gêne la chance je suis contre
cette escroquerie à eragny appel pasteur
aux secours alors que c'est trahir
pasteur on va en parler dans un instant
bien entendu girard toujours très
remonté un gerard basset l'eau du sol
gars en sandales énervé
c'est
vraiment les gars tranquille je salue
les fédérer l'ensemble des dvd à
roulettes jean michel cohen tram
jean-michel médecin nutritionniste merci
d'être là qu'est peau et le docteur
daniel sim et à son dc met ko qui s'y
met k way ou pas merci d'être là où
c'est la première fois que vous venez
fois il espère que série - la dernière
bras et ben voilà l'état généraliste et
vous trouvez que c'est une bonne
décision alors ça tout le monde a un
avis là dessus ceux qui ont des enfants
ceux qui n'ont pas d'enfants ce qu'on 12
ans non pas 12 ans ceux qui ont 14 ans
est ce que vous êtes pour est ce que
vous êtes content vous avez un seul
petit truc à faire danser sur les airs
c'est le faire avant que vous la foule
dans la gare
ce serait magnifique valérie benaïm
alors valérie bénaïm on le sait c'est la
bonne élève un bien entendu de 2,7 de
cette crise du copine valérie bénaïm
tout ce qu'on lui de 2 10 de faire elle
fait les toits et c'est bien moi je vous
explique cyril blesson j'ai pas dit que
c'était j'ai pas dit que c'était mal non
non ça vous plaît j'ai pas dit que
c'était mal mais c'est vrai que valérie
bénaïm c'est pour ça il ya géraldine
maillet et valérie bénaïm c'est les deux
premières de la classe du pot vide non
mais c'est quoi le respect pour quelques
années j'en voyais à castaldi aussi y
comprend rien mais il est content
mais je vais dire je suis comme benjamin
d'ailleurs je ne comprends rien
c'est ce que j'ai raison que je ne sais
pas et comme je sais que je ne suis pas
médecin je j'écoute la vie de 99% des
médecins et je les assume à 99 noms
alors faut
il
est étonnant mais la valérie boyer 16%
sont vaccinés quant à la wii des
médecins se sont figés à quoi il est
alors interdit travailler si c'est ça
alors je suis si non c'est pas vrai du
tout moi c'est pas vrai du tout ça c'est
des chansons de l'absolu et dans les
soignants il ya à peine me touati 60%
si vous le permettez je collectionnais
les propos moi je suis une citoyenne
j'allais dire lambda je n'y connais rien
je n'ai pas fait d'études de médecine
n'ya pas mais j'ai la trouille mais
génère une victime de la terreur durant
des mois personne n'est pas moi je ne
suis pas une victime mais je ne la
laverai jamais une victime je suis une
femme j'ai une mère de famille j'ai des
enfants je suis responsable et je ne
suis pas victime je vous permet pas de
parler de moi en tant que victime je
suis sympa avec toi
les injures oui on est à présent temps
de pâques sur journée parce que vous et
moi j'écoute simplement je sens qu'il ya
l'om est quitte la récession mondiale de
la santé s'est pas simplement un petit
médecin de quartier qui dirait par
rapport à la veille c'est l'époque où
les mecs
des batailles de chapelles entre entre
différents petit médecin de quartier là
c'est un organisme mondial le
gouvernement n'écoute les gouvernements
écoutent faut donc moi je suis ici boxe
il ronge beaucoup le
louer mais ça dit que les ne fallait pas
utiliser par exemple l'enfermement les
rives et
votre enfant 46 ans
donc gérard regardant veut dire quoi je
suis contre le passe à lithaire d'abord
parce alizés il ya trois raisons
principales est encore plus sur les
enfants premièrement c'est illogique ou
bien vous croyez au vaccin si vous
croyez au médecin c'est votre droit ou
fait vacciner vous êtes protégé donc
vous n'avez pas présents dans merde et
les autres qui ne sont pas d'accord ou
bien vous croyez pas aux vaccins si vous
croyiez beau vaccins nous a aucune
raison d'après vous êtes cet actif de
demander que les autres sa maxime
puisque tout merlin vaccin il marche pas
donc c'est illogique souplet les deux
plus belles filles elles n'étaient pas
deux des plus belles filles du plateau
sont d'accord avec gérard sandales
notamment
après la deuxième et bref bien moi je
moi je suis complètement d'accord je
trouve ça mais absurde qu'on oblige les
enfants sur vacciner déjà pour les
parents c'est une farce et c'est un
choix à prendre qui est assez important
et puis c'est la porte ouverte à tous
comme vous dit depuis le début c'est à
dire que dans ce cas là on les fait
vacciner dès la naissance sauf quand on
fait quoi des enfants qui ont des
problèmes de santé on fait quoi si a des
répercussions quand ils vont grandir et
puis le vaccin permettez moi non plus je
connais rien mais on est d'accord qu'il
empêche pas la transmission et il n'y a
pas de viagra vous réduit chez les
enfants il n'y a pas de
mandat avec on a avec nous le docteur ce
mécano jean michel cohen gens comme vous
êtes pour eux je suis pour et je
voudrais vous répondre monsieur vous
avez dit tout à l'heure le vaccin pour
principe c'est de contenir un antigène
will follow accède à pau principe
produire des antiques non nous on aurait
la preuve à venir des antigènes vous a
qu'à regarder les sépare les noms mais
un léger
il n'y a pas de raison d'être vacciné si
vous croyez au vaccin vous ne craignez
rien la prolifération des mutants qui
existe à l'heure actuelle sont
simplement liés au fait que le virus
continue à circuler parce que c'est
parce que seulement
vaccinés sont fous totalement de ce que
vous dites on comprend rien et nous on
est on veut savoir est ce que vous êtes
pour ce que vous êtes contre nous se
compose on se pose la question comme
alors c'est même pas le vaccin en plus
se passe a dit c'est quoi un enfant ça
peut être aussi un test pc avec tous les
jours
teulet toujours
sortir des crises copains on faire si
vous êtes pour jean-michel pourquoi je
sais simplement pour parce que je
considère qu'il faut limiter la
circulation du virus deuxièmement parce
qu on a vacciné 5 milliards d'individus
sur la terre qu on a vacciné déjà plus
de 60 % des enfants de 5 milliards c'est
faux lui a levé 5 milliards de doses en
istrie l'une est toutefois y avoir 5
5 milliards douze ont été 7 2 fois en
foot à la télé non l'alaric a pas lieu
samedi chose c'est qu'ils arrivent déjà
60% des enfants de plus de 12 ans ont
déjà reçu au moins une dose de vaccin
est quand même parler des effets
secondaires j'ai entendu je t'ai entendu
parlé tout à l'heure les effets
secondaires jamais on a surveillé autant
une lente où celui-ci jamais
nous tenons le pkk
c'est pas vrai
l'agent ce rocher qui ont fait pas que
sur cette terre j'aimerais qu'on demande
à guillaume genton après on aura le
témoin d'agglo sandrine au delà du fait
que ce pas tout moi je le trouve honteux
et liberticide ya aucune logique dans sa
mise en oeuvre on veut vacciner les
enfants on veut leur imposer à moins de
18 ans
veut leur imposer à partir de 12 ans et
2 mois c'est vers quoi 11 ans et 6 mois
à 11 ans et 7 mois on n'est pas concerné
par le peuple ça existe non on veut
l'imposer dans les activités
extrascolaires mais pas à l'école ça
veut dire quoi que le couvent il
n'existe pas à l'école donc tout est
fait en dépit du bon sens en fait ça n'a
aucun sens si c'est du chantage pour
vous faire vacciner si on n'a pas de
sens s'il
tente ou résister à tous les chantages
dans ma vie alors ne pas accepter
maintenant fait ça doit au lavandou site
à tous les jeunes vers des skis pour je
suis très étonné oui j'ai changé d'avis
pendant l'été
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi j'ai
regardé les résultats des essais
cliniques sur pfizer et modern age élus
d étude australienne et avec ma fille
qui avait 12 ans la lan l'a13 balle
avait 12 ans on a discuté on a décidé il
était d'accord c'est un moment aussi
dole à vacciner alors vous ignorez les
étudiants du site n'a aucune dehors et
c'est moi non mais comme vous me dites
que vous avez lu les études des
étudiants maliens ne les études des
essais cliniques faiz aurait moderna
il paraît que c'est pas avant 23h suit
pour vous évader pour ça c'est votre
droit le plus strict ça mais par sa
mère et moi c'est très prosaïque on peut
être contre ou pour le patient était il
est là donc en ce moment on a essayé de
dresser un barrage au temps des signes -
de brèches possible
tout le monde s'est posé la question
tout ce qu'il est devant moi j'ai pas
d'espoir de 12 ans donc je me pose pas
la question mais si j'avais un enfant de
deux ans je me poserai la question est
ce que je le fais vacciner ou pas je
vous le dis pour l'instant moi je l'aï
déjà dit ce serait non mais voilà tir il
connaît bien ce serait maintenant les
frais non tu confond encore une fois le
pas samedi
c'est
tout les 48 heures arrête de déconner
c'est moi personne à aller vite moi je
peux le faire je dis la vérité ouais je
gagne bien ma vie scolaire t'imagines
yoga 48,6 il a trois enfants mais est
toujours
des mecs et x et poussins c'est à coups
de ferrara calme-toi font des
connecteurs beaucoup mais la voile agira
c'est pas toi la pub d'un genre
[Applaudissements]
si je dis la vérité on se plaint de ne
pas être d'accord posez vous la question
vous ici autour de la table puisqu'il
n'y en a pas un qui a des enfants de 12
ans ou d'aller
à 12 ans et bah vous avez alors poussé
contre voilà mais parce que vous voulez
mais chaude
une page d'une part cyril sa salle à
manger pas super envie de vous pécho je
suis prêt à me revoilà on est cousin
j'ai un enfant qui va avoir 12 ans là au
moins au mois de novembre à l'heure
devant ce jeu vous allez faire il aura
12 ans jean rien qui a 15 ans j'en ai un
qui à 20 ans j'ai trois enfants j'ai
trois garçons c'est beaucoup d'enfants
j'ai beaucoup d'envié beaucoup travaillé
pour la france ah oui vous vous les
connaissez au moins
les leaders alors oui
je suis d'accord avec valérie quand
valérie dit on ne sait pas dans le doute
moi c'est vrai que je suis assez
sceptique et que pour l'instant pour le
moment je n'ai pas envie pour le moment
de faire vacciner vacciner ciment parce
que je me pose la question je m'inquiète
je me dis est ce qu'il y aura peut-être
c'est mon secondaire ses moyens
elle s'appelle simon ses jolies
[Rires]
jambes c'est jean michel klein qui lui
aussi à nice tu as bien un
nutritionniste qui me donnent des leçons
sur
michel j'adore jean-michel de bon bref
mais on a vu par exemple à la fois le
professeur à hook est venu s'exprimer
ici c'est le plateau il a dit voilà les
enfants voulaient pour sarah meier qui
en 17 mois comme un fou là dessus il
n'était pas comme un fou les deux sont
là quand on a déjà une combine mois six
mois il a déjà ulcos vide il a dominé
comme il l'a été à symptomatique ça qu'a
dit le professeur raoul j'écoute quand
même c'est pas un havre est un abruti il
à dire quand on a contracté le qu'ovide
c'est la meilleure manière finalement de
résister contre des russes
si ce nom c'est pas un argument bas de
gamme pour une maman jeu l'attaquant
martin s'est énormément surtout
autour de chasse il ya une grande
ignorance et ya beaucoup de cas sont
sceptiques les scientifiques
croyez que depuis la disparition de la
marque je serais tellement souffert à
l'ecosse et même si
mécanisme mais moi j'ai jamais entendue
depuis cette pandémie autant de fausses
informations de gens qui ont des
certitudes alors que la science je
rappel c'est le double aspect donc des
dates moi je suis évidemment je suis
évidemment pour cette vaccination parce
que je vous rappelle quand même 1ère bac
deuxième bac troisième bac on avait
l'impression que le virus il en faisait
qu'à sa tête 4e vague pourquoi la
quatrième vague fait pschitt a un petit
peu forte heureusement ce qui se passe
tel est le nouveau c'est parce que la
population et les
majorités chercheur et des souhaits à
long terme et c'est faux et août a dès
lors on avait un enfant oui je sais pas
si vous utilisez beaucoup de médicaments
avec lui dans le moins possible c'est le
dieu mais je trouve qu'on devrait
davantage faire attention à la quantité
de médicaments qu'on avale tous les
jours
un vaccin faut rappeler quand même
regarder sur 20 ans ou 30 ans regardez
derrière vous l'histoire de la médecine
l'histoire des scandales sanitaires il y
en a eu plein il n'y a rien sur les
vaccins si china série soeur collider
scandaleux c'est loupé le poids qu'il ya
eu des vitrines à meuh non mais s'ils
sont reconnus par là c'est un accueil
houleux vous free to play et
les téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
moi je vous le dis je parle à beaucoup
de l'eau et beaucoup de gens me disent
moi les enfants jamais mais voilà tout
le monde mais il y en a plein qui le
disent dont sandrine mère de quatre
enfants qui a très peur du vaccin et de
l'avenir de ses enfants pourraient le
rendre la vaccination obligatoire pour
les enfants sur un vrai drame et se
passe à une terre est catastrophique
vous avez quatre enfants de quel âge et
ben 10 depuis hier pour un après ces
douze noms 11 pas bon ça commence vous
connaissez vos enfants
oui bien vient après j'ai 16 et 30 ans
dacquois 30 ans à vide est encore la
maison non
alors donc vous avez peur parce que là
vous êtes concernés oui deux pour deux
nuits alors pourquoi qu'est ce qui vous
fait peur moi je sais pas en fait c'est
qu' il est encore expérimentale ce
vaccin en fait on sait pas du tout ce
qui va y avoir dans quelques années on
sait pas dans quel état vont être nos
enfants moi il est hors de question que
cette valse vaccin viennent sur sur le
sait vous avez peur
vous a jamais expliqué qu'on gêne avec
le recul j'ai des avis non je suis
désolé ce qu elle va bien gérer amis
mois la mère de ma meilleure amie le
lendemain du vaccin embolie pulmonaire
le mak oleg sa fille se fait vacciner et
comme par hasard elle a les problèmes
cardiaques faux au bout d'un moment on
se pose quand même pas mal de questions
maintenant dans dix ans qu'est ce qui va
se passer et les glandes qui poussent
sous les bras et tout ça il ya tout ça
j'ai eu aussi des allemands
beaucoup et nous avons beaucoup sandri
la prison en droit vous parler
sinon vous avez peur en fait vous avez
peur et vous voyez des trucs autoroutes
mais oui ça m'est radio d'entre elles
sont en fait qu'est-ce qu'elle fait son
boulot à eux fait l'avocat du diable
vous le dis voilà moi qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait sandrine elle fait comme plein de
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent elle
calcule le bénéfice-risque s10 moi mes
enfants ils sont très bonne santé oui
mais vous sentez bien moi je vais
prendre le risque peut-être de le
déterminer alors que pour la danse tout
va bien et là dans la rue ça va bien
c'est ce que tu dis alors bien sûr vous
allez me dire oui mais il faut penser
aux autres pour surprend pas mais si les
gars là temps 12 10 ans il faut arrêter
là c'est là on a les appels à la paix
mais un moment et je ne sais comment
pensent les gens et on sait qu'à un
moment on pense d'abord à ses enfants je
vous le dis et que ses enfants on se dit
peut-être moi je vois bien prendre le
risque de faire vacciner mais pour les
enfants j'ai pas très envie non plus
donc à plein de gens qui se disent à un
moment c'est pas non plus il ya c'est
pas des fous qui se disent assez d'yeux
des personnes qui sont allées chez son
psy d'action peur pour les enfants
antifascisme a donc fait juste pour les
en raison des maximes et pourtant ils
ont du mal à anna sauter le pas matthieu
delormeau qui est xavier des enfants
jeux l'ignorent mais cet accord va très
bien mais c'est quand même fascinant on
al impression qu est le méchant
gouvernement qui veut une valve le
vaccin et puis elle est il est gentil
nous qui va pas paniquer des meilleures
ventes y en a que je te parle que je me
diras fait poser la question quel serait
l'intérêt du gouvernement est de nous
faire vacciner les enfants s'il y avait
un risque quelconque qu'elle serait
l'incarnation et là je voulais vous
parler comme ça on sera comme dans les
chaînes info
c'était jean pierre diener jean michel
cohen a réuni avec la science
ça va on nous a dit au départ l'astra
zeneca et aucun problème pour y aller
apprendre nous allier à bananes ont
finalement non c'est pas pour les c'est
à plus de 50 ans et
les plus de 50 ans
on accorder une autorisation après elle
s'est fait vacciner car elle le sait les
gones attaquant je conçois qu'elle ait
peur mais on a eu tellement
d'informations à propos du vaccin à
l'heure actuelle que je constate
qu'elles en ont marre et je n'ai je
voulais te plaît l'astra zeneca on est
d'accord qu'au départ c'était pour tout
le monde est au bout d'avoir
guillon c'est mon rêve de faire une
série s'arrête
nous aime ça mais on parle assure qu on
est d'accord on élève dans ma couille
gilles ans presque
vraiment je dis pas qu'il ya des mecs
moi j'ai vacciner beaucoup avec l'astra
zeneca et il ya parlé dans mon
expérience j'ai zéro paie pas vous dire
moi je suis pour je suis pour le lâcher
pour les xamaxiens pour l'instant les
adultes pour les enfants et je le redis
je me pose la question ici mon fils
avait 12 ans je pense qu'à 90% je
l'aurais pas fait si
ces gens qui habitaient
je me suis
arrêté
vous savez comment vous parlez vous pour
vous parler comme ça tu avais toujours
les mêmes arguments et vous permet
l'analyse arguments sinon
tu sais vacciner toi même d'être des
beys maladie mais et alors les gens
michel kunz et des vaccins qui existe
depuis des mois
jamais eu un vaccin ou on vaccinait 4
milliards le continent entre 4 et 5
milliards de wons dire aujourd'hui que
vous êtes sûr et certain à 100% que le
vaccin il y aura pas des répercussions
danse dans 2 3 4 5 10 ans oui disent en
effet à long terme sur les vaccins on
hallucine a vu son placard on a réussi
le coup
sûr le fameux gardasil le vaccin contre
le le papillomavirus on avait eu des
doutes on dit ce n'est pas seulement le
nombre de cancers regarder les héros du
cancer on adopte
également varier mais les mails une
histoire mais les mecs du temps mais pas
du tout de l'autre côté alors ça ça ne
supporte pas les gens qui disent tu te
mets d'un côté ou bon on n'est pas dans
le coup et non parce que là tu suives on
est juste des citoyens qui se posent des
questions à un moment j'ai ouï dire on a
entendu tout et son contraire on va pas
vous dire qu'au début les masses non ça
sert à rien après wimbledon mais
l'extérieur après non tu dois y c1
maladie ouais bah oui ben alors
on a la chance pour une fois d'avoir eu
un rapidement qu'à
perdre le rythme puis moi mais je veux
pas prendre le risque pour les enfants
cyril le problème c'est que ceux qui
sont comme toi n'ont rien d'autre à
proposer donc qu'est ce que vous
proposez des gamins de 12 ans ne ramène
pas locaux vides et moi je
l'ajouté ratures internationales
montrent que les enfants ne ramène le
virus à la maison
mais pas le virus
c'est
une étude de l'insee sur l'enfant des
comptes un monde aseptisé chez les
diables sur tous les sujets mais la
fédération française de pédiatrie et
tous ont dit que l'enfant ne ramène pas
le virus à la maison
aucun enfant de fils de connie
c'est simplement une escroquerie
télévision
enfin c'est ça le problème mais c'est
dans une famille vous avez plusieurs
malades alors ce qu'il dit
est ce que tu as eu voilà j'ai pas vous
répondre alors
comme médecin je suis désolé moi je
crois au secret médical
personnel mais je refuse de répondre à
la question quand on exprime son opinion
et qu'il faut être transparent alors
je le secret médical est une des
principes de la nique à ses passions
s'est pas brisé ma tournée
vers tout le monde et auprès des jeunes
sont ceux à qui on veut j'ai pas du tout
envie de jouer le maintien des congés
pas du tout envie répondent à celles et
ceux qui disent le contraire
vous avez des sessions de ville
[Rires]
openskies pouvait faire ce que tu es
tout est cher et est ce que vous voulez
gerra je le redis ici on est pour sortir
de cette klein complète donc vraiment
voilà on est pour le passé ni terre on
est peut-être pour le vaccin et la voilà
qui donnent leur opinion mais on est
pour entendre toutes les obédiences moi
je vais vous dire j'en ai assez que tous
ceux qui sont qui se posent des
questions et tous ceux qui disent on est
un petit peu sceptique ces petits qu'il
soit mis de côté bien sûr ils soient
pris pour des fous et ce soit des parias
de la soutenant pendant ce temps
michel je t'aime beaucoup mais tu parle
un peu comme ça quand tu dis oui mais
alors ces outils issus des pins il en a
marre d honneur je m'explique
jean michel vous êtes des donneurs de
leçon on en a marre des donneurs de sang
n'est pas d'honneur de logicil
ceux qui ont peur non ça personne aura
bravo voilà donc c'était très honorable
d'avoir peur je pensais mais j'ai peur
que pour ça et on vit en fait j'ai comme
vous réguler ces voix là et je l'aurais
pour rassurer je les considère pas comme
des parias je leur explique des fois on
est d'accord dès fois j'arrive pas à
convaincre c'est pas grave parce que moi
je suis pour la n'arrivera pas vous
qu'on se respecte par contre les gens
qui nous assènent des certitudes mais
aussi c'est un super papy rené c'est un
support 806 il ya des conséquences sur
le plateau c'est une erreur regrettable
bon les chéris on va se retrouver dans
un instant parce qu'ils vont se calme un
petit peu s'en va dire gg juste un truc
à dire pour ceux qui sont contre le pass
annie terre demain c'est tous 10h wagram
au maire de
faire des manifestations pour la liberté
qu'il manifeste sa tentative de
traversée non je peux pas marcher
longtemps alors le sens désolé
mais effectivement j'aurais manifester
ici non d'accord va très bien en tout
cas on va voir ce qu'on pense et espère
que la coiffe toutes les stations en
commun pour à 21% la 78 pour s'aimer